[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
and uh one of his good friends and my
new friends graham stefan has dropped by
uh
big time real estate youtube guy
everybody knows who he is netflix famous
oh yeah four million subscribers on
youtube that's pretty impressive it is
it's uh and it's incredible to be here
because i really feel like i uh got a
lot of my start watching you and you
were the one that really forged a path
on youtube before i even started uh so
seeing you do it first gave me almost
the permission that wow maybe i could do
it too yeah and and then the weird thing
is i actually didn't forge anything it
was just youtube versions of this show
it was just youtube watching in while we
do this show that's all i did and and
our youtube team
clipping that stuff up and running it
around but uh graham got his real estate
license at 18 years old he sold over 130
million dollars of residential real
estate he owns a bunch of real estate i
won't say how much i happen to know
because of some stuff we taped earlier
today but uh has done very very very
well in the real estate world and is uh
well known okay so i got my real estate
license when i turned 18 too three weeks
after i turned 18 years old my parents
were in the business though yours
weren't what inspired you to get into
the business the truth is that i didn't
have good grades in high school because
i just wanted to work and when i didn't
get into college i thought i have to do
something for myself i want to get into
doing something where i could be my own
boss and i thought well i could just go
into real estate i get my real estate
license and so as i was getting my
license i go to open houses talking to
other agents and in the process i just
fell in love with it as a career so once
i got licensed i began working at
coldwell banker and just instantly i was
obsessed with it it's all i wanted to do
i just wanted to work and so for those
first really four to five years i would
work seven days
10 to 12 hours a day but it never felt
like work and that's what i loved about
it is that i could see incredible
properties meet people that i would
never ordinarily come into contact with
make great clients friends connections
it just the opportunity was limitless
so when i got my license at 18 um
i had like a suit that didn't fit real
well and one suit the other suit was
like a disco suit
and these were my dress-up clothes to go
show houses in
and i had like a tom selleck mustache
remember magnum p.i you know please
bring it back dave bring it back
and uh because i thought it made me look
older right because i knew i was just a
pup
and uh i still
had trouble getting people to take me
seriously because i was so stinking
young
did you run into that
oddly no but i think a lot of people
gave me a chance because i was so young
so starting at 18
uh and i look young now even i'm 32 and
you know i still get like early 20s or i
could i'm sure i could pass but i think
in that sense they saw that i was really
dedicated to helping them and i would do
anything and that was my advantage i
think early on is that i would take the
deals no one else wanted to take and i
saw that as my opportunity that there's
all this business out there that isn't
worth anyone else's time but when i'm 18
like earning a few hundred dollars a big
deal for me and so i would take on that
business
and i would work 24 7. so if they call
me at two o'clock in the morning i'll
get back to them i'll pick up the phone
i would pick up the phone if i'm
sleeping at night uh it didn't matter
i'd respond to emails at midnight uh so
i would do anything and i think because
of that
people felt comfortable and they knew
that i also wasn't sophisticated enough
to like ever screw anybody over so they
knew i could never take advantage of
them i couldn't lie to him i couldn't do
anything besides just do my best and
that's what i did
so
how old were you when you bought your
first piece of investment product 21 21
you bought your first rental house and
you paid cash for it cash yeah that
means you were making some money as an
agent yes yeah i really did my best to
save as much money as i could and uh you
know in the beginning i saved because i
didn't know when my next commission was
going to be
and so sometimes i would go a few months
without earning a dollar but i was
working like 12 hours a day and other
months i'd make a lot and so because i
didn't know i just figured well my
default should just be saving as much as
possible
and i just continued doing that and just
focusing on work but saving and then
when i got to a point this was 2011 the
market had really i felt bottomed and i
started noticing some of my clients
beginning to buy like the smartest guys
that i knew began buying real estate and
i had this money saved up and i thought
well if they're all doing this too maybe
there's something to it and so i started
spending my time uh you know alongside
helping clients is well now i'm going to
look for myself and let me see all these
properties and figure out an area that i
could buy in and that's what led to that
your youtube viewers know you as being
frugal jack your co-host says you're
cheap
um
so
uh
i mean
is all you do is like working pilot
money i mean what do you do you have a
life
uh i love my work and that's i would say
90 of the time i just want to work um i
don't like sometimes saturdays it's uh
it's hard for me because the market's
closed i love just being involved like
making videos i love it so much that
like that for me is fun
so i don't really feel like i need much
other than just being able to work
um as far as expenses go i mean it's
a lot is discretionary um
all you can eat sushi i would say is my
big treat is like wow 30 all you can eat
sushi in las vegas notoriously you don't
spend money on coffee you prefer to make
it at home you'll use old coffee and put
it in the fridge i bought you some iced
coffee this morning because i knew you
were struggling and so that was my
donation to you thank you but the reason
we struck up this friendship was because
we reacted to one of your tick tock
videos where you were talking about how
the best financial move you ever made
was living on less than you make and
that has been one of our principles
since dave started 30 years ago where
does that come from why are you not out
there living the flashiest of lifestyles
just dropping money left and right
i always just i think i naturally
enjoyed just saving money it was a weird
sort of obsession of mine where i felt
like you know that was something i had
direct control over how much money i was
to save and i took it almost like a
challenge to see like how could i cut
back and how could i optimize my
spending to get the best bang for the
buck and a lot of that was think it was
strategic it's you know could i would go
out for dinner or i could make the
dinner at home and my experience was
just as good if i have a friend over or
you know if if i'm going out i'll get an
appetizer instead of an entree because
it's just as filling but it's you know
half the price so i just find all these
little ways to save
and i just it became a habit but i
enjoyed it i think part of that was like
figuring out like you asked me earlier
what what the the most frugal thing that
i would do and it was using grocery bags
as
bags bags i didn't want to do it because
any money trash
i have the grocery bags i don't want i
don't want to waste them i'm going to
throw them away and they work just as
well so now you're a minimalist now it's
trendy and now it's trendy yeah but now
we gave it now we gave it our friends
gave it a name that's it so good stuff
graham stefan is our guest this segment
he has one of the top youtube shows on
real estate and finance over almost 4
million folks subscribing be sure and
check him out there on youtube and we'll
be on a coming episode someday out there
uh that we worked on today uh this
morning before we got on the air here so
rich people are all selfish and greedy
and they only look out for themselves
you ever heard that one all the time
all the time um i personally believe
that and not not all the time but just
in a broad sense that people are off
they often make money in proportion to
the amount of value they provide so i've
always seen it in terms of how many
people i could reach is is how much
value i'm providing
and a lot of what i talk about is really
just living below your means investing
consistently and thinking of different
ways to improve yourself financially and
that's just also what i'm personally
obsessed with so
i just talk about things that i am
personally doing and find enjoyment in
and try to add an entertaining spin to
things
that's one of our core values here is
marketplace service if you help enough
people you don't have to worry about
money and i don't see any evil in that
inherently you seem like a nice guy to
me thank you so there you go you got my
path pass the test thank you but you
really you're helping a lot of young
people especially who are wanting to
build wealth and they're not wanting to
do a job they hate and wait 35 years to
have money now part of that leads to a
lot of people being broke right how do
you kind of guard against that when
you're giving advice oh gosh i feel like
there's a way to do it safely and
smartly that's not like hypey i
i i'm personally not the one to like
risk it all i i'm actually fairly risk
adverse and i really prefer to take a
safer approach where i just don't like
losing money so if i can stay away from
that in common that's for sure yeah so
if for me losing money is so much more
painful than making so i like i try to
steer away from losing and if we can
improve in one way it's uh you know
making sure you keep what you have
thanks for dropping by my friend thank
you i really appreciate it i'm honored
to have you with us graham
graham stephen ladies and gentlemen be
sure and check him out on his youtube
channel you will be visiting him with
about four million of his closest
friends this is the ramsay show